Andy is in Morgantown West Virginia hi
Andy how are you all pretty good Dave
how are you better than I deserve what's
up uh I'm currently uh debt free um have
a really good job uh and uh right now my
girlfriend are talking about marriage
and she has that uh I've got savings we
got retirement I got annuity I've got
properties uh way to go uh how much do
you how much do you have in non
retirement savings uh well we're just
regular savings about a hundred four you
do what do you make a year and then
anywhere from 80 to 120 you're big time
saver very God and how much how much
debt does she have probably probably a
hundred hundred and ten maybe all right
and how long have y'all been dating by
two years okay excellent about two years
excellent and what is what coming that
does she have a house which I'm not
worried about that which you know I do
properties and stuff um but student
loans she just thought negative equity
in cars okay tough like at my main thing
is do i before we get married because I
don't I don't do dead I'm big and
investing um do I pay it off before no
get married no okay the day you go on
the honeymoon though okay but you know
I'm trying to wait a little bit to see
if maybe she can you know kind of get in
the right groove you know what I mean
same page is what I'm on yeah you need
to pour that cuz let me tell you you are
a big time-saver
you're a very frugal person a very
organized and detailed person am i right
it's a very okay she's not right and
that what I'm worried about and that no
I wouldn't worry about that's okay Larry
Burkett used to say to people like just
like get married one of you is
unnecessary
usually you marry the opposite and
that's okay she's going to help you to
lighten up and have a life and you're
going to help her to be more responsible
and organized
that you got sent you to each other but
that that very thing that is attractive
now will be like you say it's a worry
when you come into the relationship and
the number one cause of divorce in North
America today's money fights and money
problems so you guys really need to dive
into this subject and have a lot of
discussions in your premarital
counseling time okay prior to getting
married to make sure that you're on the
pain
I don't mind our having the debt I do
mind how she feels about it right it's
not a big worry to her yeah that's a
that's a problem because it's a big way
you're worrying more about her to hear
she saying I make good money but I work
six to eight months a year it's seasonal
so I save and you know you you know I
cover for when I'm off you know and I'm
getting that I mean but you're very very
but it seasonal you're very careful and
you know you guys have got to get on the
same page about money so I go through
Financial Peace University as pre
marriage training together so that you
can talk about this crazy guy they've
REMS you in how he says be on a budget
and he says be out of debt and how he
talks about investing in the you know
and then if you can get aligned on that
after you're married you combine
everything which means you need to write
the checks and be debt-free but don't
pay off somebody's debt you're not
married to ooh bad medicine and idea
never do that this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]